Let's say say we want to change
a compile flag in our Java project.
We can just add some configuration
to the compile Java task.
However, unlike simple Java projects,
which have a finite set of tasks such
as, compile Java, jar, test, etc.
Android projects can have
an indeterminate number of tasks,
depending on the build types and
product flavors we have declared.
Additionally, the names of
these tasks are generated, and
they're based on the name of
the particular variant the task is for.
Not only that, but these tasks
are created at a very late stage of
the project configuration life cycle.
Which means, in most cases,
we can't directly reference
them in our build script.
Essentially, we need
to solve two problems.
First, we need a way to reference each
task used to build a particular variant
without having to know
the task's actual name.
Quite simply, we want to configure all
the tasks of a particular type for
every variant.
Second, we need a way to defer
the configuration of that task
until after all of our build
variants have been created.
Which really just means that we can't
configure the task until a task exists.
The first problem is solved by
the Android Gradle Plugin itself,
which groups all the information
to include the tasks
associated with any given
variant into a single object.
There are three main types of these
objects, the Application Variant,
the Library Variant or the Test Variant.
The type of variant we need depends on
the type of project we're building.
Application Variants and
Library Variants are created for Android
Applications or libraries respectively.
And Test Variants are created for
the on device test APK.
Each one has its own specific
properties, but they all have common
tasks, like compiling Java,
merging resources, and so on.
So the Android Griddle plugin is
nice enough to neatly package all
the information about a variant for
us, but the problem remains, how do
we reference these variant objects?
This problem is solved by what
Gradle calls live collections.
Essentially, as the Android
plugin creates variants,
they are added to a fancy
type of collection.
These collections allow us
to define configurations for
objects that don't yet exist.
Instead, Gradle will remember
our configuration and
execute it when a new object is added.
We specify this configuration
by calling the all method
on our variant collection.
For example, if we wanted to configure
all the Java compile tasks for
our application variants
to add a compiler argument,
we could do something like this.
This will now configure each Java
compile task for each of our debug build
types, regardless of how many
product flavors we have configured.
Also, you don't have to try and
guess what the final names of
each of those tasks might be.